don't ask don't
can ask i'm bloody asking what the what
the hell you do no obviously
mark wahlberg is playing sully in the
upcoming uncharted movie
and i'm so glad that they've finally
given him the mustache now in case you
don't know
the film's been shooting for quite a
while now it's pretty much all wrapped
up and we've slowly started to get
teasers about the film
and i think it looks really great a
couple of days ago we got our first look
at tom holland
in his nathan drake pose and it wasn't
drake's deception it actually gave me
drake's erection what uh no sorry
it did you know it did win me around
quite a bit now originally i thought
that tom holland wasn't gonna fill the
shoes of nathan drake as
you know he's just he's just a wee lad
from england and
he just didn't carry the demeanor that
drake had for me drake's sort of an
american wisecracker and though tom
holland can do that sort of thing
he seemed like a boy whereas drake you
know he's a man however
you know the take in the film it's very
much the first outing
unless they have a chance to do a lot of
origin stuff so
casting a younger actor when i look at
it it does make a lot of sense
now the first look at tom holland has
him in the the wide class as the cosplay
nathan drake outfit
with the sheer the the ring necklace and
the pants
and his hair slicked back but you know
what he did win me around
and i think that he looks really good
now another big question that's been
floating around the film
is will mark wahlberg be adopting
sully's mustache
well it looks like he actually is as the
star posted a short video on instagram
this morning
and i think it looks absolutely amazing
he was also an actor that was a bit
unsure of the casting over
but after seeing him with his mustache
yeah he's he's completely changed my
mind
it's funny how all that can happen maybe
they should have left it in in justice
league
now i first saw this story posted on
comicbook.com
and they said that the reveal has
basically tore the internet in half
as people have been frothing at the
mouth for details about the new sony
film
i'm sure women have been frothing
somewhere else are you having that lads
comicbook.com state that when the young
heroes picture
aka tom holland popped up online there
was a mass amount of fan outcry
asking where victor sullivan was in all
of this mess
i don't know if it was that much of a
mess now little did the angry twitter
users know
hold on hold on and say comicbook.com
yet they weren't that angry
little did they know that a second
reveal would be coming in just a few
days
unsure its production has been all over
the place as a result of the coronavirus
pandemic
and it looked like there could have been
significant delays but
luckily for the studio and its fans
things seem to be all the way back on
track
so yeah really really good to hear now
in addition to all of this
tom holland actually came out and said
to ign that mark wahlberg is gonna be
amazing as sully
the stunt department have been out there
in berlin and they've done an amazing
job already
prepping the stunts and it's going to be
an exciting one
so yeah i was initially a bit tepid on
it but i'm slowly starting to come
around
now i've just realized i haven't even
introduced myself so if this is your
first time here this is the heavy
spoiler show
i'm your host paul and on the channel we
talk about games comic books movies tv
shows and a lot more
really going to depth in this stuff so
yeah make sure you subscribe
if you're new here and you just want one
a lovely british guy to narrate things
to you because you're too lazy to read
i'll let you off though because it is
sunday now in case you don't know
uncharted the movie is going to be a
fresh take on the games and it's not
actually going to follow any specific
storylines
it's going to kind of go off into its
own universe much like the tomb raider
franchise
and though it will obviously have motifs
that are famous in the game
which i hope we get that plane scene
they are going to be doing their own
thing
now that is probably the best thing to
do as in the last couple of days the fan
base have really came out and said
please don't mess this up sony please so
i'm kind of feeling like this post by
mark wahlberg was also just
a goodwill gesture to show that they are
handling things the right way
when the movie was in production we did
get some behind-the-scenes looks at it
and mark wahlberg wasn't donning the
mustache which got a lot of people
worried because hey
what is the biggest thing about sully
other than his amazing personality
it is of course the lovely stash that
gets all the girls
however it does seem like they're
they're really getting this down and
you know i'm quite excited for it now a
couple of days ago as well
nolan north also visited the set and he
said
it's like looking in a mirror proud to
have tom holland continuing the drake
legacy
absolutely smashing it thanks for the
set visit
tom holland 1996. i think he's eight
years younger than me that's
that's a bit of a punch thanks for that
nolan now currently
the uncharted movie is due to release on
the 16th of july next year
although with the pandemic you know you
know there could be
a delay say if uh if cinemas aren't open
or something like that however
the the film is wrapping up and shooting
has been done so i am very excited tom
holland's gonna go
and start on spider-man very soon and
yeah
there is a lot of goodwill surrounding
this project for me at least
i know a lot of people are disappointed
but i try and go on things with a
positive mind state and
i was quite negative towards the film
when when the casting was first
announced but you know
they seem to be going in the right
direction now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the first look
if you agree with me if you disagree you
know what that's totally fine i can i
can see
why you don't like the looks make sure
you comment below either way and if you
enjoyed this video please drop a thumbs
up
and also check out our breakdown of the
news that deathstroke is going to be in
the cider cut
in a more fleshed out role don't forget
we're also giving away three copies of
the marvel phase one box set and all you
have to do to begin with the chance of
winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe to the channel
and drop a comment below if you want to
support us so videos like this get made
then please click the join button below
it costs 99 cents a month and you get
access to early videos
so it's definitely worth doing if you
love my voice which
will be weird if you do anyway thanks
for sticking till the end of the video
that was a good sell
i'll see you next time yeah take care
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]